me now paul tweed an international uh
media lawyer joins me now paul thanks so
much for for joining us what do you make
of this decision largely as expected or
a surprise
well certainly in the latter part of the
hearing it was looking very bleak indeed
for rebecca vardy uh so i think i don't
think i certainly wasn't surprised uh
whenever i heard the judgment today and
i think the problem is once you decide
to issue defamation proceedings
and jump onto the libel bandwagon it can
be very difficult to get off it
not least due to the fact that legal
costs start to mount very very quickly
indeed particularly in london
and so this
looks to me like a case that you know if
when you stand back
and look at it with hindsight
you know you really have to question
how you know anyone would want to risk
what appears to be between two and a
half and three million pounds which is
likely to be the total cost bill uh
facing uh rebecca vardy here at the end
of the day so it is it's really you know
in days gone by
uh we used to be concerned or talk about
the level of damages awarded
but since the juries have been abandoned
uh we are now the the legal costs are by
far
uh the biggest factor that people have
to take into account before they embark
in this type of case i want to come to
this estimated cost figure in a moment
because it seems absurdly large to to me
but before we do that just just remind
everyone so who was who had to prove the
burden of proof in this case
well the the action was brought by
rebecca vardy she sued colleen rooney
for defamation on the basis of a tweet
uh that uh
colleen rooney had had posted
now uh colleen rooney she stuck by what
she said
and pleaded truth the defense of truth
and in other words she uh went into
court to justify what she said and was
also uh claiming that was in the public
interest although that did not come into
play in the judgment once it was found
once the judge decided that there was a
strong element of truth in the subject
tweet so basically uh rebecca vardy
failed to prove her case
and uh colleen rooney mounted a
successful defense and
she as a result is able to recover
at least 70 percent of her costs and
rebecca bardi is going to be stuck
obviously with 100
of her legal costs so i mean how is it
possible is 2.5 to 3 million a
reasonable estimate in in your eyes i've
heard that number thrown around today i
mean it wasn't
that complex at trial was it wasn't that
long lasting
the problem in in london was to say in
particular there because the law was
changed in 2013 there are
more uh interrogatory hearings and
applications and case management
conferences
all to determine whether there's maybe
serious harm or whether
certain meanings can be put before the
court
and all this takes time and if you take
up a lawyer's time it costs money
still i'm staggered i can't believe it
costs that much but but i'd take your
word for it you know a lot more than i
do uh on this does rebecca vardy have
grounds for for an appeal are there
other people
that perhaps could be blamed in some
form of way or that she'll feel hard
done by her agents thrown out a lot in
various discussion points
well that's obviously a matter for her
lawyers her own lawyers to advise her on
i don't
see the grounds for an appeal but again
i was not uh
involved in the case uh you have to
always be very careful in passing
judgment even in the case of this nature
where a judgment has been given you've
got to rule the facts and the the trial
judge to be fair heard everything and
has given a very very categoric and
detailed judgment having heard all the
facts and certainly that i think it's
going to be a very very difficult case
if an appeal was minded but i understand
from the comments made uh post uh the
announcement of the judgment today that
an appeal is unlikely
uh and finally do you think that this
sets precedence going forward or or will
maybe just in a more minor way warm
people off similar attempted libel
lawsuits
no this has been happening from time
immemorial you win some you lose some
even in the past couple of years i mean
we've seen different results on both
sides of the atlantic
some of the cases are before a judge
sitting alone
some of the cases are before a jury
and each time it has become more and
more unpredictable as to the outcome but
that has always been the case it's very
difficult until the court hears all the
facts is able to assess the credibility
of the witnesses which is sometimes a
very difficult thing for even a party's
own lawyers to assess until all that is
done
the outcome is very much up in the air
and very much
up in the expense of air i should say
well paul i'm very grateful for you
joining us not least for free given that
we know
how expensive lawyers like yourself's
time is these days so thank you again
paul for joining us